the most famous news story of all time
unfolded behind me the headquarters of
The Washington Post the story was the
Watergate scandal and the Post reporting
on it helped bring down a president the
story began when five men were caught
burglarizing the Democratic National
Headquarters in the Watergate complex as
it happened they had links to President
Nixon's re-election campaign their
capture sparked a flurry of news
coverage but then it quickly died down
five months later Richard Nixon was
elected to the presidency by a landslide
and the break-in at the Watergate
complex seemed almost like a footnote to
the campaign and it might have remained
there except for two young Washington
Post reporters Bob Woodward and Carl
Bernstein they pursued lead after lead
revealing in one instance that Attorney
General John Mitchell had a secret fund
that was used to spy on Democratic
officials the Nixon administration
charged that their reporting was biased
and baseless and they pressured the Post
publisher Katherine Graham and the post
editor Ben Bradley to call off the two
young reporters Graham and Bradley
refused but they had their doubts if
what Woodward and Bernstein was
reporting was so accurate and so
important why were other news
organizations not following up on the
story
eventually the Post reporting convinced
Congress that there was something to the
story and Congress began its
investigation that in the end led to the
resignation of President Richard Nixon
the post watergate coverage illustrates
the press at its best pursuing its
watchdog role under the First Amendment
carrying out its duty to keep an eye on
those in power and to reporting when
they engage in wrongdoing